so I sense you're about to tell me
something about Trump is he running that
well uh that that's not what I'm going
to tell you about I'm confident he is
going to run I'd be shocked if he did
okay okay I don't know anything anymore
anybody else knows about that but I
thought maybe here now there was an FBI
raid and Mar-A-Lago
uh a warrant was taken out uh a warrant
is uh supported by an affidavit uh and a
judge uh U.S District Judge his name is
Bruce Reinhardt executed a warrant uh
and at 9 30 or so in the morning uh
around I think it was the eighth or so
of this month of August about 9 or 10
FBI agents swarmed in on Mar-A-Lago and
went through the Trump residence and
removed about 15 boxes of information
at first we didn't know what they
removed uh Trump wanted the list of
stuff revealed he wanted the warrant
unsealed and revealed uh and then he
wanted the underlying affidavit unsealed
and published all of which ultimately
happened and these are all unprecedented
for the warranty to be revealed let
alone the underlying underlying
affidavit and that's to protect the in
the investigation that's why they don't
want it revealed and apparently can I
pause you for one second just understand
the story so so they raid does it
immediately break that they did it or
did people find out later like did
people know that Dave it's hard to say
when it broke but it broke it broke
fairly quickly yeah keep in mind Trump
has uh cameras everywhere
Trump was not there right but that was
not there Melania was not there he was
elsewhere but he was watching The Raid
apparently uh on video and that video
has not been released yet but he was
watching it uh his son Eric found out
about it contacted his dad and told his
dad it was going on when this happened
exactly I can't tell you but the news
rope within hours or so of this of this
raid so they basically just busted in If
he if he's not there I mean that's right
they they went in um they were armed
um and around eight or nine agents came
there and
um this was never happened before and
based on the revealing of the warrant
revealing of the underlying affidavit
revealing of commentary that I of people
I respect he is Accused Trump of having
probable cause to violate the Espionage
Act by removing
information pertaining to National
Secrets National Security from the White
House when he left the White House he's
accused of um violating an act that
private hibits you from destroying
insensitive government documents and
he's and he's Accused at least there's
probable cause that he committed
obstruction of justice apparently 15
months ago or so
there was some back and forth about
documents that he removed and some of
them were returned and it appeared that
they were voluntarily they meaning uh
the FBI the National Archives working
with Trump lawyers about what he took
and normally when the president leaves
the president often takes documents that
are perceived to be documented he
shouldn't have removed and you work it
out right this was not worked out and a
lot of people feel that
this double standard here it should have
been worked out uh Garland gave a
statement unusual after this happened
because half the country was was was on
fire not on fire physically which is
angry and said that um we always try to
get these things resolved in the least
invasive fashion and he suggested that
Donald Trump was being difficult uh
refusing to turn over documents he
should have turned over so we had no
choice but to do this
and God this sounds like just such an
extension of all the stupidity
so I wait so
they're accusing him of taking a bunch
of stuff so they bust in there they take
the documents have the documents been
running when you say busting I don't
think they knock down a door but I think
they knocked on the door at 9 30. uh
nobody got a heads up Trump's two of
Trump's lawyers were there but they were
not allowed in to witness a search but
they were in in the house when it
happened
they weren't allowed in to witness this
word no so they can just basically the
FBI is this how it it's supposed to
operate they can just basically get into
your house take all your stuff no one's
allowed to win there's a warrant
allowing you to search certain places
and apparently they even searched
melania's wardrobe
okay so I would imagine uh a lot of
people are not happy about this I would
imagine Trump is fighting this I mean
what's going on
uh Trump uh has now demanded that they
appoint a um a marshal an independent
Marshal to go over all of the documents
uh underlying the warrant and to make
sure that uh what was done by the FBI is
on the up and up that's also unusual so
Trump has filed a motion to have an
independent third party uh take a look
at everything the FBI did on that day to
determine whether or not they should
have done it man they really don't want
this guy running for president like that
that what else could this possibly be
about like does he really have documents
there that he wasn't well that's unclear
and I tell you somebody that I look at a
lot when these kinds of things happen
because I think he's fair and that's uh
Andrew McCarthy on Fox he's not a trump
guy but he doesn't hate Trump and he's a
former U.S attorney uh and he wrote a
very long piece that came out a couple
days ago in the National Review and said
Trump probably took documents he
shouldn't have taken from prop Trump
probably was uncooperative Trump
probably made public statements about
whether he was cooperative when in fact
he probably wasn't and there may be an
indictment forthcoming uh choosing him
violating the Espionage Act violating
the act that I said earlier that forbids
you from destroying government documents
and accusing him of obstruction of
justice he now believes that there may
be an indictment coming Alan dershowitz
angry about the whole things feels that
there won't be an indictment feels that
this is double standard Elder fills is
double standard right for a couple of
reasons Hillary as you know clearly
violate the Espionage Act she had a
server basement bleach bleach on which
he sent and received information that
was classified denied that she did turns
out she did and then later on she said
that she never sent or received
information that was stamped as
classified she lied and said and turns
out she did and as you know James called
me to this big presentation and talked
about how careless she was how Reckless
she was but the last minute he says but
she lacked the intent right well the
relevant part of the statute Dave does
not require
and so a whole bunch of us right and I
can't just do a bunch of bad stuff and
not having and then you have uh Eric
Holder Eric Holder was under a subpoena
to turn over documents pertaining to
Fast and Furious that was a gun walking
thing that uh for some reason the
government did presumably to trace where
these guns were going and the bus the
cartels for buying these guns well the
guns got loose and at least one of them
was used to kill a border patrol agent
and so uh Eric Holder was subpoenaed by
Congress to turn over the documents he
didn't do them didn't do it he was found
in criminal contempt of congress the
first and only AG to be done to have
done so Republicans took him to court
and over a course of five years holder
was able to negotiate back and forth
ultimately turned over the documents we
think
um and okay so wait wait I get the
double standard right one more one more
down Sandy Burger remember that one uh
that was he was Bill Clinton's National
Security advisor and uh Congress was
conducting hearings on whether or not
Bill Clinton this is before night after
9 11 might have known something or
should have done something to have
stopped it so burger goes to the
National Archives steals documents oh
right stuffs them in his pants gets
busted and got a slap on the wrist and
so these are just three examples where
in my opinion if we were being
consistent uh they should have been
punished far more harshly Hillary wasn't
punished at all and as you pointed out
destroyed a bunch of uh documents or
under subpoena youth bleach bit bleach
bit Yeah and got rid of all them and
nothing happened to her so even if
Donald Trump my long way of saying even
if Trump took documents he shouldn't
have taken even if he's uncooperative
how is it you came down on him with a
hammer and those guys got to pass right
so okay so the double standard thing
that's just standard stuff right we're
used to this you know you're on the left
you're going to get the pass you're in
on the you know it's basically a mafia
game where if you're all in on it
together you let your people off and you
always go for everybody else so is the
country just insane right now I mean
basically when this happened I now I
assume that just lit a fire under Maga
and his MSNBC and CNN saying wait are
the walls closing in on the guy the
walls are closer these freaking walls we
got you now we got you now
that's exactly what you're saying and if
this story still burning hot right now
because you said what'd you say on the
8th or so eighth or nine something like
that it happened about about a month ago
not quite a month yeah okay and right
now the issue is whether there'll be
some independent uh uh magistrate or
Marshall or I forget the term to look at
all of this to determine whether or not
it should it was fair if you talk they
want to make him Jesus
all their lawyers say Donald Trump
should not have taken these documents uh
with outrageous freedom take the
documents this is a guy who does not
play by the rules and uh he got what
he's just what he deserves do we know
what any of the documents are though
like do we actually know okay there is a
document in there that had some Secrets
yeah
there was a list of all the stuff that
was taken out although the affidavit
underlying the warrant was heavily
redacted I mean you look at the sheet
there's a bunch of black stuff all over
there so you're not sure exactly what it
is right they were looking for or what
it is they have
um but um it does not appear that
um we still know we still let we don't
know